نظم نشطاء اعرب وا امريكيون مظاهره امام
مقر سكن مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سوليفان وسط واشنطن للتنديد بالموقف
الامريكي في الحرب على غزه وطالب
المتظاهرون سوليفان بايقاف الاباده
الجماعيه التي ترتكب بحق الفلسطينيين وفق
وصفهم كما رفعوا صور اطفال قتلوا على يد
الجيش الاسرائيلي للتذكير ببشاعه الحرب
على قطاع
غزه وط جنه جنه جنه تم جمع عشرات الناشطين
امام مقر سكن وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
اوستن في منطقه جريت فولس بولايه فرجينيا
للتنديد بما وصفوه بالابا الجماعيه في
قطاع غزه ورفع المشاركون الذين تجمعوا في
وقت مبكر العلم الفلسطيني وشعارات تطالب
بوقف اطلاق النار وصورا لعدد من القتلى في
الحرب وصناديق تمثل شركات الاسلحه
الامريكيه ملطخه بالدم واستمرت الوقفه
اكثر من ثلاث ساعات واصدرت الجهات المنظمه
لها بيانا جاء فيه ان الدعم الماليه
والسياسيه الذي تقدمه للولايات المتحده هو
الذي مكن اسرائيل من الاستمرار في ارتكاب
جرائم الحرب فلسطين
عربيه